[Music]
when the Taliban retook control of
Afghanistan it became an extremely
hostile place for many including British
citizens the UK government's advice is
don't travel there three men who did are
now detained
Kevin Cornwall had been working in the
country for Charities as a medic until
what has been described as a
misunderstanding a firearm seized from
his hotel room by the Taliban we know
the weapon was licensed we're familiar
with where the the license was issued
from and the context that it has and so
it's I think incumbent on the Taliban to
consider the implications of what
arbitrary detention could cause given
the dependency on the country for a
Mr cornwall's arrest was almost three
months ago he's been detained ever since
along with the manager of the hotel he
was
still his identity hasn't been released
both men are being helped by Scott
Richards whose company presidium Works
in Conflict zones he says his associates
in Afghanistan are trying to negotiate
the release of the two detainees
progress came with a phone call to their
families providing some much-needed
reassurance the belief we had that these
men were not being armed that they're
not being poetry is correct
Scott Richards says he discovered the
men's detention during his own research
to me that says if you guys hadn't come
along and sort this information out and
got actively involved in these
negotiations these men wouldn't have
stood much of a chance just with the
foreign office representing them that's
probably a reasonable conclusion I mean
it's so evident by our participation
Home Secretary was clear the government
is in talks to
risks to people's safety if there are
British citizen abroad then the UK
government is going to do whatever it
takes to ensure that they're safe and
the government is in negotiations
also detained is Miles Routledge a
British man whose holidayed in some of
the world's most dangerous places
posting about it online there's risk and
there's a ward but for me there's only
reward because it's so much fun let's do
some shooting with the Taliban
he was evacuated from Afghanistan when
U.S forces pulled out of the country but
he returned it's unclear why he was
arrested
there is hope that the men could be
released to coincide with the end of
Ramadan but as their families wait
desperately for news their fate remains
in the hands of the Taliban the
agricultural Sky News